if secure stamina is so insistent that
no rules were broke and why on earth is
he offering to resign
listen what really has struck me about
all of this is the difference in
attitude between kirstalma and others
he shows that there is integrity and
honesty in politics that all politicians
are not the same and at a time of
increasing cynicism about politics and
politicians not just in britain but
around the world i think it's a really
important stand to take
and and he's done it and he said you
know if i am
um if the if the durham police find me i
will resign
one of the people advising him to to
make this statement then
before he made the statement he
obviously spent a bit of time speaking
to colleagues and i was one of the
colleagues that he spoke to yes
he
can't be clear durham police are
investigating now aren't they and
effectively durham police are will have
a say on who leads
your party and in fact who is the the
deputy leader that's what it comes down
to
both angela rainer and kia stammer have
said
that they have not broken any rules but
that if they are fined then they will
resign
and that's the right thing to do
and i think that it shows them in clear
contrast to the systematic party making
that was going on at number 10
where there were leaving parties
arriving parties birthday parties abba
parties parties with karaoke machines
you know parties with cakes parties with
cheese parties with wine
and more parties going on at number 10
than at any other address in the whole
of the country and yet a prime minister
who lives there and works there that has
to do with the conservatives
your party is in crisis is it not
tonight
no we're not in crisis kierstama hasn't
broken any rules
and he is not going to be fined because
he hasn't done anything wrong but he has
made the stand which is that if the
police decide that he has broken the
rules and don't do fine him then he will
resign and that's you know that's the
right thing to do listen this is a guy
who has spent many years as the chief
prosecutor in the country he knows how
important rules are and indeed
politicians ought to be held to a high
standard we're the ones who pass the
rules we ask our parties to vote for
them the least the public can expect at
a time of collective trauma you know
when we were all having such a difficult
time during the pandemic and making such
huge sacrifices the least we could have
expected was for our politicians to
stick to the rules and indeed it must be
highly embarrassing uh emily thornbury
for a former director of public
prosecutions to be in this position
facing all these questions
the
we know don't we we know from the sunday
papers if it if it's true that there is
an attack unit at number at uh in in the
conservative party who have been working
with some particular people in durham
and coordinating tory mps who have been
tweeting writing letters putting
pressure on the durham police to reopen
the case the durham police have opened
the case they've got an incident room
with six police officers in it if they
decide that kia has broken the rules and
find him he will resign but he hasn't
broken any rules the guy was just having
something to eat and if he is found to
have possibly breached covert rules
rather than specifically getting a fixed
penalty notice will he then go it's
going to be hard for him to stay on
isn't it
you either break covert rules or you
don't if you break coveted rules then
you get a fine you know there's no gray
area on this you know the rules are
clear and if you broke the rules then he
gets a fine um and therefore he will
resign but he was just having a meal you
know he was just having something to eat
he was out on the road he was a
politician out on the road and we do eat
and and that's what he had to do and he
ate late and he worked afterwards and
then he went back to the hotel and then
he got up and he did it all over again
you know that's how we do it is that is
that right though was any more work done
after this meal it was late as you just
said that on a friday night
sure but the hours that one works um you
know as a as a politician on the road
are pretty pretty long and we have these
things called op notes and um and
i think the copy of that has been leaked
the papers and that shows
how it works so what we do is we have
when we're out on the road we have a
sort of a skeleton which is written out
of all the things that we need to do so
what time does the train arrive who's
picking us up where are we going how
long are we staying there how long do we
have you know where are we going next
you know all these sorts of things so
the people who are around us know what
time what time does emily have to leave
you know no she can't talk to that
person any for any longer she has to
move on that sort of thing so it's it's
that kind of ops notice the sort of
thing that we have you know that is the
basic structure on that we have like you
know if you're on a train then you have
the time to go through the speech and
make sure that you're okay about it and
sign it off or sign off quotes and at
the end of the day i can tell you as a
politician who spent a lot of time
campaigning on the road the last thing
you do before you go to bed you sit down
with your staff you go through what
you're doing the next day you go through
the ops note of the next day and you
work out right where's the speech how
what what kind of state is it in am i
meeting any journalist which ones am i
seeing what are we just one quick just
one quick answer if you would uh this is
highly embarrassing isn't it for your
party it means you can't get on uh with
the business of challenging the
government while the spotlight is on the
leader and the deputy leader right now
oh we will continue to challenge the
government they don't need to worry
about that